everybody this is the daily Denny I'm
Denny and I'm switching things up a
little bit today because if you're a fan
of psychic mediums and carpool karaoke
then you're gonna be obsessed with live
times new series seatbelt psychic the
show features renowned medium Thomas
John who surprises unsuspecting
passengers with messages from their
deceased loved ones now I know I know I
know some of you are probably giving me
the eye roll emoji right now but I had a
chance to take a spin with Thomas
himself and let me tell you it was in a
word emotional so I gotta say this is
the first thing we're actually having an
interview in my car little new for me
feel I believe that well this you're out
you're in the driver's seat because
obviously I want this to tie into your
show so just with the premise of
seatbelt psychic so it is a show where
people think they're getting into an
actual ride chair but I'm their driver
and I am a psychic medium and so they
have the opportunity if they want to get
a message or a reading about their
future yeah if you miss your wedding
your skeptics who actually opted out
yeah um yeah where people just they are
skeptical and they're like I don't
really want to do that well what are you
feeling well maybe you know people have
it's interesting but people definitely
have some pretty strong reactions to it
she's really happy to ear in love
there's no way you know that I am a
natural medium so I was actually born
this way when I was four years old I saw
my deceased grandfather and he gave me
messages and since then I have developed
it and stuff it's just such a part of my
world that I kind of jokingly say that
like if I ever woke up one day and I
didn't see dead people I probably like
freaked out so I know the feeling for me
but I saw a spirit I would not know what
to yeah probably call you well do you
mind me asking do you see or feel
anything now
I'm sure yeah we can do we can see what
comes through and DD feel open to having
a reading and stuff I dunno but I feel
like
you're you're going the next year for
you I'm sensing is going to be really
really significant for you and there's
going to be a lot of I see you the the
current opportunities that you have it's
like that staying out of it how it is
but I see things being added to things
the other thing I want to tell you like
it feels like expansion like I'm getting
there's a lot of expansion around you
the other thing I want to tell you is I
don't know if it's Ellen or Helen but I
kept hearing that name and I'm actually
hearing it more than once so I don't
know if you do you do you have a Helen
or Ellen around you Helen yes my my
grandma your grandmother okay you're
you're living grandmother yeah but is I
feel that I'm getting it like more than
once so is there more than one yeah my
my grandfather's mother Helen okay so
your grandfather's mother's house Helen
Joo yes and as she passed she's passed
so so it's like your great-grandmother
yes because I'm feeling a woman coming
through that's in spirit name Helen I
really was feeling that I did get a
sense though that you did know her right
you got to meet her a little bit me her
once when I was very young and I feel
like it's interesting she she's bringing
up to me and who's the D connected to
her the GE connects to her my
grandfather Deni okay so that's her son
or something right but I want to tell
you that this this Helen woman even
though you didn't really know her a lot
in the physical world I do feel like
she's one of the people that watches
over you and you know you don't have to
do it like tomorrow but I did feel like
she was talking about that you know in
life like she's showing me all her
different you know all the different
wings of the family and it's like
everybody's kind of on a different path
and I feel like she's just telling me
where you're going you're going into
this really positive place like you know
you're gonna be doing really important
things in it and in a way it's very
different from your family I feel like
she's just telling me like don't forget
your roots don't forget where you
from even if you don't see everybody all
the time it's like I feel like she
doesn't you know it's important that you
you know connect connect a little bit
she looks so like these grandparents
that she's talking about her son like
he's still alive right okay yeah because
I feel like she's making me feel like
there's a there's a close connection
there are you guys yeah yeah cuz I feel
like she's talking about like it almost
felt like more than a normal
grandparents oh yeah yeah they became my
legal guardians yeah so you know I feel
like she sheets she sees it and so the
other thing I want to talk about is it's
like something like your yeah you're
gonna have more of your more of your own
own opportunities and stuff I feel that
and I wanted to tell you there's another
hundred
do you have an Eileen okay
your grandmother is talking about Eileen
just make sure that you're staying in
touch with her it feels important and I
want to say I'm just I don't want to
really go too much into this but I feel
like I'm getting a lot of happiness
around you in your personal life so I
feel like you're either with someone
that you love a lot or that's gonna be
happening for you really soon but it
kind of feels like it's like right
around you now but it's interesting cuz
your grandmother's kind of like she's a
little bit your will you to your
great-grandmother but she's kind of like
she doesn't want me to go a lot into it
right now but she's telling me that
there's a lot of happiness around this
that you so I feel like she's really
happy for you okay yeah I'm laughing
because it's complicated it is anything
coming through from a woman my mother
maybe yes
hold on but I don't feel she so she
didn't die recently no yeah why am I
saying like s a and D cuz her maiden
name sand of all okay I do feel that
she's here just like it's weird
sometimes I don't know why it works this
way but sometimes you have to ask like
it's like by you I don't know it's like
you brought her here yeah mom um you
actually have been you had over him she
had a difficult life she's telling me
she had a lot of challenges in life and
she really wishes that things were kind
of a little bit different with you guys
but it doesn't mean I see white roses
with hearse whenever I see that it means
she comes in a lot of like she's in a
state of peace she wants you to know
that she she really is in a state of
peace over there I actually feel like
this woman was kind of coming through a
little bit when I started to talk about
Eileen mhm so does she know Eileen at
all that's her daughter this oh okay our
mother oh that's her so is your sister
yeah and this woman that's her daughter
correct yeah she just one of the things
that your mom wants you to know is she's
she's really in a peaceful place on the
other side I feel like she's in a lot
she keeps showing me like I don't know
it feels very quick when she passed her
like it's like very abrupt she's showing
me like there's a it feels very abrupt
in I don't know if she always shared
this with you but your mom is telling me
that she carried with her in life
sadness a little bit she did she had
some sadness and it's like she wants you
to know over there she doesn't really
have that anymore it's like she's kind
of free from that but it's like it's
when she doesn't really want to talk
about that she's like oh I don't want to
talk about that but I get that from her
that she was like she had sadness she
carried some sadness with her but so
proud of you I feel and a lot of times
they do you know this all this she feels
like oh my god you know she's she's very
she's really really very I feel very
happy about Halden
you understand about the quick passing
though right yeah she'd um she died in
the cracks okay yeah cuz it feels very
joseffer I feel like she really wants me
to emphasize that so I feel like that's
maybe her way of saying like I left my
body quickly it wasn't suffering I
wasn't in pain I do feel that but she
yes she I feel like she's connected to
you a lot so yeah we were pretty close
yeah and look for butterflies because
she's saying that that's a sign that
she'll actually use to connect with you
so it might not be an all the time thing
but she is she is bringing that up I was
pretty shook after this I'm not gonna
lie and now you guys know a whole lot
more about me but that actually makes me
happy you guys can see Thomas John in
action for yourself when seatbelt
psychic premiere it's July 11th on
lifetime all right I need a drink after
that one so I'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]